oh go and rest my name oh man
Scottish our High Command - yeah City
Gloria okay hey la tell it hey I just
smoke it for me not okay oh [ __ ]
don't said I quit that but my prom night
whoa all right like it you little bang
fun in that
hey in the on hand
I'm Terry shower like it fun today
clapping I later you're [ __ ] okay
sorry sorry know how I control pop shake
gal can we add channel a so Kyra
yeah we sure don't inside for an
acquittance time oh hello that means fly
so I can put it up on a on a ship or no
thank you hey but you they see me roll
don't say my role of the Martha but rely
or me later okay but you're a ladder for
me
yeah okay
yeah you come over for this buddy I shot
an eyeball on him
good summer taste those Emeril are some
hot are utterly a lot of shaky Fung em a
little landed the Smith see okay quick
good the village two miles
GAD I mean bus accident that daughter
telling okay until tonight
let me check it out
but fry ladies you have not quit doing
yet oh hey oh oh oh
sacred a.m. yeah that mean yes I hit it
alright
career did you have enough god oh yeah
that my damn touch okay yeah that's
gonna been oh come to me man
come to you back you may come out if
it's flare bit that something in Jack a
yak yeah
whoa said man it's it bothers man hey
done the hell is my head ah say this I
be like come on dad let's go support the
song and I have that all right hey Chris
okay let's get dirt and pine top target
in then solo look for to find yet it's
not break anything
oh what a career that tryout face I mean
I have a shark or a the man okay oh yeah
okay let me slap oh no matter yeah okay
I'm gonna hit it
slap what right-hander
hey hey okay yeah okay bye five yeah
okay come on
okay doctor morning out no muck table
and they okay hey okay I was just say of
trauma padded leave it all right
Sunday I must have sit back on hey oh
okay I'm in heaven
okay shove it Narada city I know
everything about anything
hey now we're honest my father dad oh
yeah Oklahoma the bed with it yeah yeah
yeah
Rama oh I would be Terry okay Tom poured
on us
commander honest I can't slip up oh okay
whoa oh hey become us you'll all right
okay add some taken bonito oh yes
Himalayan Morita but I am sick - who
succeed I am today Jim and panache it's
money after a recent division until the
framingham code Tetris and that meant I
want am I
the back flap pocket ah and that time
but what okay good night night okay
later than hack read the mail phone
Canada Oh Oh Alan you're a cop dad okay
so land opponent oh don't Finn still in
did it in the rear ended a room up Mary
so man I also do belt know that what for
shock face okay okay
night okay yeah so yeah we jump on
before pin it so so I have it so yeah
they so at it so you have it so yeah
just getting it songs oh yeah I thought
you quit then I hit a fish again
ah okay buckled up oh Emily style ah
very room that I had met them I forget
about him
yes hi is that Oh
[Music]
oh oh yeah yeah I dunno they come in it
so but Marie okay darling it so Michelle
is if that there was sauna new come with
garlic guarantee yeah okay that all
solute that we had read then Sun ski
comments Irene alright I guess I get
targeting's now anyway to everyone like
usually I make this and a lot of people
like it because a lot of sweet Swedish
and Danish and Norwegian Scandinavian in
general people who watch but like I add
subtitles and it takes me forever to add
as a please don't complain I made 32
episodes in English yourself anyway
that's pretty much it
like review Shinyoung subscribe comment
birthday and I okay I said something the
about tip of last
hila oak Thomas 40 or should I quit some
brofist caramel activate
Oh
no way my mouse go